Natalie Portman is set to star as first
lady Jackie Kennedy in the political
film Jackie out December 2nd at the
movies premiere in New York Thursday she
told et she's standing with her in
Donald Trump and Hillary Clinton's race
to the White House I'm very excited to
see Hillary become president and it's of
course been disappointing
you know election cycle to have to hear
the vulgarity as opposed to people
talking about the issues which I think
Hillary has been great about bringing it
back to that when there's a lot of
joyous Natalie admits she had some tough
shoes to fill channeling the iconic
FLOTUS on screen I was very nervous I
mean people are very aware you know what
she looked like and what she sounded
like and what she moved like and it's a
it's challenging because you want you to
approximate that as much as possible and
luckily there was a wealth of
information out there that that I
couldn't drop and jackée's famously
fashionable ensemble helped the actress
get into character the film takes place
really after her husband is assassinated
the clothes are a sign of mourning and
really prefer you to to the emotional
side of her journey it always helps to
put you in character